Esquire magazine facing backlash now for
the cover with this headline quote an
American boy
what it's like to grow up white
middle-class and male in the era of
social media school shootings toxic
masculinity me too in a divided country
joining us right now is to discuss this
who read the article for comprehensive
purposes is Michael Mills host of the
Michael Knowles show Michael why is this
profile controversy controversial in
your mind I can't quite figure it out I
think that the controversy actually
justifies the article doesn't it it's a
very brave piece and it's brave because
in this moment the left has decided that
it hates young white men in this era of
identity politics and intersectionality
young white men are the one group that
the culture permits and actually
encourages people to detest to condemn
we saw this with those Covington boys
waiting for their school bus in
Washington DC after it turned out that
the kids had done nothing wrong everyone
had jumped to condemn them the senior
culture writer at BuzzFeed and Helen
Peterson came out and said regardless of
the video you should understand why that
face caused a visceral reaction in so
many that face the face of a young white
teen boy they have driven themselves on
the left so crazy with the politics of
victimhood the identity politics of race
and sex that they have convinced
themselves that there is this one evil
category of person the Yale Daily News
student newspaper the other day just ran
a piece about how all-white brown haired
young men are evil this is the the
consequence the toxic consequence of
leftist identity politics and I give
Esquire a lot of credit for running this
timely piece well Michael it you read it
and it is a simple thing you you know
exactly what this kid is going through
in his life and talks about his mom and
everything else but some have suggested
it is tone-deaf to be putting him on the
cover of Esquire during Black History
Month
well they don't yet have a middle-class
teen white boy month so I don't know
what month would be suitable for them
run it it's not as though Esquire hasn't
run covers of black men they've had two
black men at least on the cover in the
last year chadwick boseman and donald
glover they had at least another two
black men the year before
idris elba and Pharrell I think that
really what has happened here is the
left has found a conclusion and now they
are searching for an argument the
conclusion being we should never have
any sympathy for these awful oppressors
the young white men and the argument now
saying that February is an inappropriate
night for that but if they had done it
next month they would have called that
one inappropriate - the problem for the
left is the subject not the time Michael
the editor-in-chief of the magazine says
the task of grappling with the world has
to be more complicated for kids than
it's ever been
a series on growing up now white black
LGBTQ female that will continue to
appear in coming issues so it looks like
they will highlight yeah what it's like
to grow up in each of these situations
it's a series of course and it's
important in this case because as the
article points out the this culture is
very confused and a kids such as this
and all American kids are receiving very
mixed messages
we're told that men and women are
exactly the same there's no difference
whatsoever and yet even men can become
women women can become men and yet we
have to treat women with one very
specific attitude and men very
differently we're told race doesn't
matter we're told that we should treat
everybody based on the content of their
character and then as this kid has found
out we're told that certain people
should shut up people who are white and
male should not be allowed to hold
opinions based on the color of their
skin or their sex as though their
opinion were not determined by the
content of the opinion itself they're
working through these questions and I
think it's wonderful that that's why I
was shining a light on it it's actually
because you know you always try to find
something with an angle and his angle is
he's nachi he's just a normal kid he
likes to hunt doesn't like sports like
video games once we an engineered dozen
want to go to college just a normal
stuff so I thought that would be it's an
interesting thing to do as an editor I
can't believe it's controversial Michael
Knowles thanks so much good to see